Bonjour, je me présente, je suis Hugo bidou,
je suis le fondateur de l'association
mission croquette solidaire
et je suis le co-président de l'association
c'est pas sauvetage
enquête protectionnelle.
Étant sur le terrain,
il est fondamental pour moi que les politiques
s'en parlent de la question.
Et pour moi, le seul parti politique qui peut le faire,
c'est le parti animaliste.
Le parti animaliste est 1 parti
transpartisant et monothématique sur la question animal.
Grâce à eux, la question animale peut évoluer.
C'est pour ça que je me lance sur la liste d'élène tui
aux élections
européennes deux-mille-vingt-quatre.
Rejoignez-nous,
votez ! Partie animaliste en deux-mille-vingt-quatre
pour les animaux et pour la terre,
1 terre plus vivante !